[Music]
why do predators always die like every
movie they're in this is one of the main
questions asked by fans all over if the
interstellar high-tech alien hunter is
so deadly then why does it die in like
every movie
so besides plot armor we will tell you
how and why they were killed so let's
get to it
the jungle hunter let's start with the
og the first of these ruthless killing
machines at some point of time prior to
1987 the jungle hunter began hunting
humans he considered worthy prey in the
jungles of guatemala he was near
unkillable deadly and invisible and
armed with plasma cannons wrist blades
by a helmet and a cloak although nearly
killing everyone he was eventually lured
into a trap by dutch who figured out how
to stay invisible on thermal scans by
rubbing wet mud all over his body
anyway he used this tactic to lure the
predator into a carefully laid trap
but was almost killed if not for a lucky
chance that allowed him to [ __ ] the
predator with a huge log of wood and
that's how the first predator was
defeated with plain luck
next the city hunter as for the second
one he was more or less like the
original but equipped with a vast array
of weaponry and operated in the dense
urban settlement of los angeles he is a
good hunter but he's still a young
hunter and overconfident he became
over-enthusiastic as his quest in los
angeles went on casually attacking and
killing any armed people he came across
a government task force group called the
owlf was sent to try to catch him as
well as a seasoned lapd detective
lieutenant mike harrigan eventually came
into the battle with him harrigan using
the city hunter's own smart disk killed
the city hunter in close quarters combat
while hiding in a city's underground
within the mothership so the second one
died due to carelessness
then we come to the avp youngbloods well
the predators sent to earth to get rid
of the xenomorph outbreak were young
bloods that were also on their mission
to become fully mature blood hunters the
three were celtic scar and chopper and
were on their way to undertake an
initiation hun in an ancient predator
pyramid beneath the ice on bove island
in antarctica in stalking and killing
cinema of prey they hoped to become
blooded yelja celtic and chopper were
killed by a drone cinema called grip as
it was just an experience that got them
dead as for scar he fared better and
killed a lot of xenomorph drones
but proved no match for the queen
xenomorph one of the most powerful
variant of the alien species
next avp requiem wolf this predator was
a veteran an elite one of the deadliest
of their species that had many kills to
his name and had a lot of trophies in
his lair wolf was an elite and a very
experienced and accomplished cinema of
hunter as well when wolf came to earth
to get rid of the xenomorph infestation
that occurred in colorado
there he killed quite a number of drones
easily but had a setback in killing the
juvenile predalien queen even with all
his weapons and widths he wasn't able to
put down the predalien and he was
eventually killed while he was fighting
the predalien a kill in a nuclear
explosion that eradicated all life in
the small city of
so even a deadly elite hunter was no
match for a nuclear bomb
then we come to the super predators from
the movie predators there were two types
of predators in that movie we got to see
a subspecies called the super predators
that were bigger and physically stronger
than the hunter version
there were three of them falconer
tracker and berserker the super
predators got humans and a few alien
species to be brought to the game
preserved planet for their hunting
rituals eventually during the hun they
got overconfident and were all killed in
the end the tracker ignored all dangers
and took his time to kill the russian
spatnaz soldier who took his chance to
detonate a number of grenades taking out
his own life and the tracker as well
the falconer was also careless and did
the same thing
underestimating the humans and he dueled
with the yakuza using blades the human
got a quick strike that killed the
predator at the course of his own life
as well the berserker proved to be more
careful but due to a distraction of
fighting against a hunter predator that
was released it allowed royce
to lay a trap for him confusing his
thermal scans with fire effectually
blinding him
but even with this the predator almost
won except for the lucky sniper shot by
isabel that maimed him allowing royce to
get up and behead the berserker and
putting an end to it
now we come to the upgrade predator
the upgrade predator was an amalgamation
of various genetic enhancements into a
normal yautja which resulted in him not
really needing weaponry for a hunt the
predator was also very clumsy and
overconfident with his bio-cybernetic
upgrades that he basically didn't really
want to use any weapons or even stuck to
a proper measure
to it it served no purpose as he was
bulletproof and was physically a
behemoth compared to humans
but careless and underestimating the
humans proved to be his downfall as they
used the predator's own deck against it
to decapitate his arm first then his leg
and finally deliver headshots to it so
it was a combined effort of a group of
humans a predator hound
and the carelessness of the yautja and
also his own tech that killed it
and lastly the feral predator this
latest predator was yet another
subspecies that came down to earth for
its first time learning about the life
forms here in this planet although a
very deadly entity he was still an
unexperienced hunter he had to inspect
the food chain of the land in order to
find out what creatures are on top so
eventually when he ran into humans he
had first underestimated them thinking
they were dumb animals and then after
suffering a few injuries from battle he
quickly adapted and learned to utilize
his full talents to kill the comanche
warriors and also the french hunters
but luckily due to the orange flower
abling people who eat it to lower their
body temperature to a level of being
invisible to thermal scans naru a
comanche warrior a female comanche
warrior used it and laid a trap for the
predator and eventually used his own bio
helmet to kill him but objectively
speaking the feral should have avoided
his own weapons but maybe he was shocked
at the tenacity and ingenuity of a
female human
therefore catching a strange case of
being dead
so the main reasons for the predator
deaths due to humans were carelessness
and underestimation aside from the
nuclear strike so i hope you have
enjoyed watching this video do hit that
like button for support and subscribe
but most of all smash the bell icon for
regular updates on new videos here on
this channel till the next one take care
fam